[Music]
in Roche girlfriend news submitted by
hell no no an insect loving guy
confesses he once dated a Cucaracha [ __ ]
the cockroach he did not have a sexual
relationship with this cockroach how do
you fight a cockroach you get a
cockroach and ego yeah and in a
cockroach comes you'll it's a crawl
around his mouth
mmm I'm his wiener he sounds like a
little art Kelly to me
we gotta interview that cockroach to see
what really happened to you yeah the
Congress would ask some father know that
God right cockroach actually died oh I
didn't survive he [ __ ] it too hard
what what's going on Oh sounds about
that but nice sounds about the jet but
least of information here so this man
whose name is Utah Utah Utah you thought
you he's 25 years old he was crazy
this guy's crazy he loves he's talk but
all she doing Dewey University
University you thought he was crazy so
anyway so he organizes insect-eating
events in Japan and he creates dishes
like a bug cocktail insect pastries and
ramen with crickets and meal worms in
them oh and then he said for some reason
I have a connection with this one and I
cannot care it well look at the way Niki
is with her grass with frickin Gary on a
grande Gary honor
it's a grasshopper that she named Gary
that she couldn't get rid of that was
killing her plants she got rid of all
the other siblings but because she made
a connection through the jar that she
put him in so she can transport him
right in to me like every time she
turned it it would turn around and like
still like it and should turn the theme
I still look at her so she kept Gary and
then she found out once it blossomed
that it was a girl so he changed the
name to Gary on it Robin
is that [ __ ] still alive okay so
I mean so this doesn't sound far-fetched
anymore when one of our clothes is that
person so I get it I just loved with me
but such a good name Gary on a grande
she's creative I love her girls so much
yeah yeah so this guy he explains wait
let me explain one myth what's the
United Nations Food and Agriculture
Organization FAO when they promote his
little Falcon when they promoted eating
insects for food security
he became comfortable with coming out
about his love for bugs and sorry
there's a lump or bugs and there's like
an in love with bugs yeah yeah so then
that's when you reveal like that he
dated this cockroach for a year we
corrode he maimed her Lisa but that's
kind of weird that he eats them and he
loves them right
so she was farm raised and brought from
Africa he's the black widower and he
said that the love was platonic Oh dater
he he he no but it's platonic but by
definition he didn't date there wasn't
romantic maybe it maybe I'll show you
have friends on by a cockroach cockroach
friendzone him gorgeous eat poop this is
what he said so he said that he enjoyed
her company so much Ikey believed that
they could communicate and that the
relationship when it when she died it
obviously ended and then that's when he
ate her with reverence so he says quote
so now Lisa lives in my heart and
continues living as part of my body
lives in his toilet Ashley yeah called
her his first love this is what Disney
does to people you know that
the people it doesn't go to Germany
cricket I want a Jiminy Cricket in my
car you know there you go what's
happening normal Japanese dude is there
such a thing as a normal Japanese
well I mean I'm alright
wait legged job look at job this is Lisa
that's as normal as it gets I think I
agree I know Japanese people and in the
regular world standard of normal their
normal is different yeah and this is
what I call open and create what's bomb
but there's full of bugs where does a
bug ramen cricket I'd eat that
[ __ ] that looks good though oh
man not yeah no no no thank you
if he saw the same [ __ ] hentai manga
that I did I know why he got it to bugs
Wow because there's this one called
bondage fairy and then they're these
fairies that go around and [ __ ] all the
animals and then all the animals like
one [ __ ] juice wait what is it called
bondage fairies and it's on manga you
gotta read it and then there's this one
there's this one episode where this guy
he's got writer's block and he's drawing
and [ __ ] and he just can't figure out
what to do and then the bondage fairy
comes down and it's a it's a cerca de
that he saved earlier that day or that
[ __ ] thing that's loud in the summer
it is yeah and then it turns into a
little fairy and then he's like the [ __ ]
you gonna do with that little ass body
if she goes I'll show you and then she
[ __ ] him and he falls asleep because
she's thankful that she's that he saved
her life because she was about to get
eaten by ants and [ __ ] so he probably
read that [ __ ] literary greatness here
what in the [ __ ] did I just listen to
Japan that is wild that is Japan gotta
say what an interesting story yeah she's
like you saved my life
the humility earlier today you were
walking down the street and you did
something very very nice was it smaller
was it like human side no no he stayed
small
so so then so that [ __ ] was like this
small and in her his dick was like that
and it she was like [ __ ] with it like
that and I'm like damn dude that's kind
of crazy
you know the story yeah but the story's
good the stories are good one time the
the mole like he had problems with this
dick and he couldn't [ __ ] his wife and
then the bondage fairies came down and
they're like yo check this out like you
got some kind of emotional block because
your wife is this way you got to get
your manhood back so you need to [ __ ] us
and then the bondage fairies are like
yeah we're gonna [ __ ] and then they [ __ ]
the mole and then the moles like oh yeah
I feel confident again I can get hard
and then she went back and then they got
to [ __ ] his wife and did they make cute
little mole babies
it's very strangely wholesome every
multi-service Nora yeah like that like
the [ __ ] blind furry boy yeah yeah
they're like the police of the animal
kingdom and in the forest they help they
help the [ __ ] help everybody come and
you come yeah it's a magical place
that's what that's why people like oh
why do you want you like cartoons that
[ __ ] it's not about that man there's a
lot of emotions it's about the stories
man you got to watch these things man
some of them are like they're like a
good Korean drama but then they add the
sex that's why when people make fun of
me and they're like would you talk about
the next level [ __ ] you want to do I
want to make a feature film with full
[ __ ] like it's a porno but then the
acting is actually really good and the
story is really good it has been done
and it's called manga is called
nymphomaniac there's one is called
hentai manga that [ __ ] already exists
it's [ __ ] good you got to read it I
think out of everybody you would like
that [ __ ] you will appreciate it it's
novel you would appreciate all man's
novel plus a [ __ ] full-on Pokemon
series plus a [ __ ] porno oh my god
how can you have all the greatest things
in the world into one little book I'll
look into it
don't they do videos too again yeah but
they're not as good as the books cuz in
the comics you can imagine more alright
anyway what in the [ __ ] just happened I
just got accepted into this world that
is a [ __ ] drunk future i teleported
somewhere I just came back boom what was
that you guys should not think you guys
should know cuz you guys like anime I
thought out of you I like anime and I'm
everybody has known about anime porn
yeah but there's a huge disconnect you
don't mean
because I want to know how good these
stories are cuz anime just as good an
anime story I really wanted it's not
even like it's not even like porn where
it's like acting so horrible this was
delivering the pizza and all of a sudden
there's a dick in the box you know you
know that's cool about Japan it's like
they accept things so much and it gets a
little bit weird but it's like you know
what it is it's kind of beautiful that
you're accepting I think sorta I think
it's tight how do people do what they
want to do why be so judgemental admins
are always weird when they do like it's
called like fanservice right or it's
just literally just it's weird because
the people don't look like the cartoons
that they're drawing right so just huge
bus I don't know there's just titties
just flopping and it's like this is such
a weird thing for me to watch you know
what I mean but there's like like
animations I like it's like for example
this one called like erased it's [ __ ]
amazing like I want them to turn that
into an actual film like it's like good
like that cuz I don't like that kind of
stuff is always weird to me unless
there's like it's it's a comedy then
it's funny to me cuz there's a lot of
humor in it you know I mean enemy boobs
defy the laws of gravity oh for sure did
that's it bounces like crazy there's
that there's anime called food wars oh
yeah see that one that's humor though
that was [ __ ] funny Oh funny yeah you
guys don't remember back in the day when
you watch Dragonball [ __ ] and then
there's that scene where like Blu mosz
[ __ ] betting over cleaning [ __ ] or
whatever in a [ __ ] Master Roshi's
drooling just like that it's funny cuz
to me that's like the Japanese version
of Herbert
feels like you're making fun of what a
[ __ ] perv he is but at the same time
all the kids are getting turned on
watching her bend over and watch bondage
fairy tale read read bondage it's going
crazy man reading group together it is
crazy
not like book club it's like oh no it's
mating season for the butterflies the
butterflies they they have nowhere to
[ __ ] because the weather was different
so they got misguided I don't know I'm
just making that one up but it's easy to
you know kind of like imagine being in
the world yeah you're gonna get so much
like [ __ ] anime porn since you now
you have no idea dude Jesus
[Music]